- All right, everybody,
let's wrap up this hour
with something I'm pretty sure
will make you smile just
a little bit bigger today.
This is "What I'm liking."
(upbeat band music)
(audience clapping)
So, some dads will do pretty much anything
for their daughters.
That's certainly the case
for one proud papa in Arkansas
who's become the main model
for his daughter's fashion designs.
I love him.
Just look at this.
(vibrant band mUsic)
Oh god.
I love him.
Oh my gosh.
We have this father-daughter pair
on the line right now
watching on ABC 4029 at four.
(all laughing)
Meet Emily and Jeff, everybody. (laughing)
(audience cheering and clapping)
Oh my gosh.
Jeff, I love you so much.
I'm gonna lead with that
and you look fantastic.
- Oh, thank you so much, Kelly.
(laughing)
It's all her fashion.
- Emily, your dad's
become a TikTok sensation.
So, how did this all get started?
- Well, I've been
crocheting for seven years
and in 2020 I started
selling my designs online
and I make clothing
that's unique and perfect
for festivals and concerts,
- Yeah.
- and it was actually my parents
who convinced me to join TikTok.
I started with having
my mom model my clothes
and that went really well.
So, at dinner one night I asked my dad
if he would model my clothes too,
and he was all in.
He was so enthusiastic.
- Oh, my God.
- Pretty soon the videos were doing better
than anything else that I was posting.
So, having my dad model my clothes
has been a huge boost to my business.
- Oh my, he is amazing. It's amazing.
So Jeff, you say this
has been super meaningful
to you as well, right?
- Yes, I just really enjoy being able
to make,
to be ourselves
and just have fun doing it.
- Yeah.
- It's meaningful to me as a dad,
because as a previous entrepreneur,
I started businesses,
and you really push yourself.
- Mm.
- So, seeing her put in
the time and the research
and getting the content out,
just makes me really enthusiastic
about wanting to support
Emily any way I can.
- So it really encourages
- Yeah.
- people to know that
families can be close
and it's attainable for everybody.
- I love y'all so much.
It is such a great example
of how family is so fun
and you can get so creative together.
And girl, your designs are so cool.
So, congratulations,
(audience cheering)
you're such an amazing artist.
(adience applauding)
Thank you so much, Emily.
(audience applauding)
Thank you, Jeff.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
(audience cheering and clapping)
(Emily laughing)
- Thank you, so much.
Thank you, so much.
- And that's not all,
our season long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of FriXion, the go to erasable pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly,
just like your entire family,
so they're gonna give you a $1000.
(audience cheering and clapping)
(laughing)
- [Emily] Thank you, so much.
- Thank you, so much.
- Thank you, guys.
- That's so awesome.
- No, thank y'all,
y'all have such a blessed day
and everybody, thank you
to all our guests today,
Michael, Ellie, Jennifer, Tilly,
Dale, Chase, Andrew,
Jamie, and Emily Carpin,
y'all have a great day.
And if it's not, well, try and change it.
(upbeat band music)
- Thank you, Kelly.
Thank you, hank you, thank you.
I will never forget this.